the uncertainty principle thing called
the Casimir effect and hopefully a
little bit about black holes as well so
I guess we have to start with the basic
physics which is the uncertainty
principle
it's this weird thing that you can't
measure the position and the momentum of
a particle at the same time and actually
for this video the important one is you
can't measure the time of something and
the energy of something at exactly the
same time so if you want it you've got a
photon you can measure exactly when it
arrives if you want but then you don't
know what its energy is or you can
measure exactly what its energy is but
then you don't know what exactly what
time it arrives and there's a
fundamental uncertainty in that energy
which works even if the photon has zero
energy so if the photon fundamentally
has zero energy then there's an
uncertainty that actually you can't tell
whether it's zero energy it could
actually have some energy so that means
and a photon with zero energy isn't
there at all basically you've got
nothing there and that means that
instead even when there's nothing there
you can actually have a photon with a
suddenly acquiring an energy and that
leads to this weird effect that even in
the vacuum of space you can have photons
popping into existence for a brief
period of time so basically you can sort
of cheat nature you can borrow energy as
long as you put it back before anyone
notices and that's this trade-off
between the amount of energy you've got
on the amount of time you've got and the
more energy you borrow the less time you
can borrow it for and that means that
the vacuum of space is actually this
seething mass of particles and
antiparticles being created there are
some rules so that you have to kind of
create particles in pairs but beyond
that even in the vacuum of space you can
have particles popping into existence
and disappearing again so this idea that
vacuum is empty is kind of it's actually
not correct right that even in vacuum
you have these virtual particles that
appear and disappear so it applies to
every particle absolutely anything you
know so I was talking initially about
photons but you can do it with electrons
and positrons appearing you can have
protons and antiprotons you can have
anything you want but obviously the more
massive the particle is remember from
Einstein's famous equation e equals
mc-squared the more massive the particle
is the more energy you're borrowing to
create it and therefore the quicker you
have to put it back before anyone
notices so the least massive particles
can exist for the longest periods of
time yeah like a planet or a gold nugget
these are in principle you could create
anything but of course by the time you
get up to what on the cosmic scale of
things are then a very large masses then
they disappear on such a short timescale
that really did you know
they effectively don't exist it sounds
like it's made up but actually there are
experimental tests you can do to show
that a vacuum is actually a seething
mass of particles it's not empty space
there is this famous experiment a
phenomenon thing called the Casimir
effect that was predicted way back in
the 1940s that says that if you do an
experiment where you've got two plates
very very close together so about a
micron apart to ten to the minus six
meters apart then actually what happens
well well you've got the seething mass
of photons being created out here by
this uncertainty principle and you've
actually got photons being created in
the gap between two plates as well but
the interesting thing is because you've
now got this pair of plates that
actually restricts the kind of photons
that you can create you can't for
example create light with very long
wavelengths because it wouldn't fit into
that gap so just by having a pair of
plates although this effect is still
going on you create fewer particles in
the gap in between than you do out here
now the photons out here bouncing around
and hitting the plate exert a pressure
on it and the photons in here bouncing
around that are being created by this
virtual effect create a pressure this
side but of course now we're creating
less photons in this gap which means
there's a bigger pressure this side than
there is on this side so there's
actually a force and this force has now
been measured that you can actually
detect this force you set up this
experiment you can actually detect this
force and the plates actually get pushed
together by this effect called the
Casimir effect where you're actually
seeing this effect of the virtual
photons being created this seething mass
of virtual particles but just more of
them on one side of the plate than the
other it explains things but the main
thing it does is creates a huge problem
because if you're a theoretical
physicist you can do a calculation that
says okay so I'm creating all these
virtual particles they've got mass
associated with them how much mass am I
actually creating in the universe that
just from this stuff popping into
existence and the answer is unless
you're very careful how you do the
calculation you end up with an infinite
mess
and so actually actually one of these
problems that theoretical physicists
have that if you do the naive
calculation of just says well let's
let's let this effect go what's going to
happen and the answer is you end up with
the universe that just doesn't work
because you end up with the infinite
mass density everywhere and the whole
thing except in ''tis appearing in your
mathematics so the theoretical
physicists have to do all these clever
maths using a process called
renormalization which basically is a way
of kind of shoveling all those
infinities under a rug and not worrying
about the many
I get the impression this must be a very
faint phenomena because like for example
when a rocket ships going to the moon
it's not it's not running into a barrage
of particles that keep popping into its
part well it is but actually the oh
you're right the impact it has on the
rocket is tiny because the forces
involved are very tiny and that's this
effect of this you know again if you
just do an ID calculations that says how
big should this effect be if you're not
careful you'll end up predicting it
should be a huge effect and somehow it
ends up being normalized down to this
very small effect but it is you're right
it's a pretty small effect in everyday
life okay you'd promised me black hole
okay so we need to do another thing
before we get to black holes which is
that's the was the Casimir effect now
the thing called the dynamical Casimir
effect which says that okay so if I got
this pair of plates then this phenomenon
goes on and we have these virtual
particles being created out here in it
and on either side but the fuehrer in
here and that's creates the force now
the dynamical Casimir effect says that
actually if you think about the virtual
particles being created in here if I
accelerate one of the plates very
quickly so instead of just having them
sitting next to each other I move it
backwards and forwards very quickly some
of those virtual particles become real
so actually the things which are popping
in and out of existence some of them
actually become real particles and
there's two ways to think about this
either you can think about it of saying
that actually when you wrench them apart
that these little pairs of particles
would pop into existence and then
recombine and disappear again they kind
of lose track of each other because they
kind of get pulled apart as well they
lose their twin or all terms of you want
a duller explanation you can say that
actually the interaction of the kind of
the electromagnetic field you're
creating in this space and the metal
plate when you accelerate it ends up
creating photons from the surface and
the photons are then emitted from the
surface but either way in some sense the
energy that was originally in those
virtual photons in the gap gets
converted into real photons and you
haven't cheated it seems like you're
getting energy for nothing now but that
you know you haven't paid back the debt
but actually you have because in order
to accelerate this plate there's a force
remember and when you accelerate
something against the force you end up
doing work so actually just pulling the
plate backwards and forwards puts energy
into the system so you're not cheating
nature and for a long time that this was
thought to be kind this was just a
thought experiment and the trick is the
problem is from an experimental point of
view that actually you have to move the
plate at relativistic speeds so the
plate that you're moving backwards and
forwards has to move at some decent
fraction of the speed of light what you
just can't do with real plates
but actually just a couple of years ago
someone did a very subtle experiment
where they instead of having a pair of
plates and a gap in between they kind of
created an electronic analog of this
which is they had a waveguide which is
just something that kind of forces
photons to travel in one dimension and
at one end of it they put one of these
things called a squid which is a
superconducting device where by changing
the properties of the squid you can
effectively change the length of the
waveguide at whatever speed you want so
they could actually drive it at like
about five percent of the speed of light
so get up to a speed where actually they
were effectively changing the the gap
this this kind of cavity at those those
kinds of speeds when they did that they
found that this cavity started emitting
microwave photons so actually the effect
has finally actually been detected in
2011 for the first time so that then
gets us on to black holes a black hole
obviously you know you haven't got
accelerations in a black hole but you've
got gravity and there's this thing in in
general relativity called the
equivalence principle that basically
says that the way gravity behaves is is
indistinguishable from the way that
acceleration behaves and actually you
anyone who's ever stood in a lift is
familiar with this in that when it
starts going up when you start getting
accelerated upwards you feel heavier and
actually you've no way of knowing
whether the gravitational field unless
you can look out through the window
you've no way of knowing whether the
gravitational field of the earth is
increased which is why if you're heavier
or whether you're being accelerated
which is why you feel heavier so
everything that you know basically the
physics of acceleration and the physics
of gravity is very similar so in a in a
black hole you don't have accelerating
plates but you have gravity plenty of
gravity and exactly the same thing
happens close to the event horizon of a
black hole where you have this
gravitational field that basically the
virtual photons that are popping into in
existence and disappearing around the
black hole lead to real photons being
produced now again you can think about
this two ways either you can say that
this interaction of the electromagnetic
field with the event horizon of the
black hole makes the event horizon emit
photons or you can have the rather more
romantic picture that these pairs of
photons are being produced and then
disappearing but actually once in a
while one of the pair falls into the
black hole and then the other photon is
kind of doomed to never find its friend
ever again and has to wander the
universe forever as a real particle but
it's exactly the same physics that's
what's going on now here then the
question is how do you repay the debt
because now you've created energy and
now you no longer have acceleration you
no longer have things going moving
backwards and forward there's actually
only one place that the energy can come
from which
from the mass of the black hole because
the energy is mass times the speed of
light squared so the mass of the black
hole is a source of energy so what has
to happen bizarrely is you've got
something falling into a black hole
makes the mass of the black hole
decrease over time and this is this
process of a black hole effectively
emitting photons and in the process of
emitting photons losing mass is this
thing called Hawking radiation and why
black holes eventually have left to
their own devices will evaporate I
gather from that that all black holes
are doomed to evaporate away because
they can't help this thing happening if
their event horizon but there's so
that's certainly true but there are two
things to bear in mind firstly it's an
incredibly slow process which means that
actually you know black holes which form
very early in the universe unless
they're really low mass black holes
won't reach that stage even today and
the other thing is that actually that's
how a black hole loses mass but of
course a black hole can always gain mass
just by stuff falling into it and almost
certainly most black holes in the
universe there's more stuff falling in
that then they're actually losing by
this evaporation process so actually
even though the process is always there
probably most black holes are actually
putting on weight rather than losing it
I mean it's never been detected directly
so in that sense it's just a theory but
actually it's a pretty solid theory in
the sense that all the physics that goes
into it is we reasonably comfortably
there's something slightly uncomfortable
about this whole area of physics because
you're combining gravitation with
quantum mechanics so you've got the
gravity of the black hole you've got the
quantum mechanics of these virtual
particles and there is it's well known
that there's a missing piece of physics
that we don't really understand how to
put quantum mechanics and gravity
together but from the limited
understanding we do have it looks like
this is a pretty solid result that
actually black holes will indeed
evaporate by this process and we've got
a little detector here so in you know in
simple terms all you're doing is you're
firing some light up there it bounces
back and gets detected and then you've
got a little thing that says okay
whenever I do decks of my I'll send
another pulse up